so Jeff this is a bit of a surprise to
have me here at Kapow what are you doing
here I'm quite excited to be here I I
moved to London basically for the next
year I got here five days ago and I was
having dinner with Mark Millar and he
said what's going on with the kick-ass
two panel for Kapow and I was like I
didn't know there was one mark he said
well there has to be one can you come on
down on Saturday and I was like
absolutely some here and I just did the
the panel with Gareth and nacho and it
was fantastic it was great to meet them
so I couldn't be happier now the panel
was the directors panel wasn't as you
said you're on there with with Gareth
and not show and it said in the kind of
explanation what the panel was about it
said what it takes to be an amazing
director in Hollywood so what does it
take to be an amazing director in
Hollywood I have no idea we actually had
a quite a laugh about that before the
panel because I said I know what it
takes to be an adequate director in
Hollywood maybe even slightly slightly
slightly above average but amazing I'm
still trying to figure that out but I am
very fortunate in that on kick-ass 2 I'm
working with an amazing director Matthew
Vaughn is is producing the film and I
and I wrote it and I'm directing it so
maybe I can glean a little from him
through the process
now you mentioned kick-ass 2 there which
I was going to ask you about next so
thank you very much for a great segue
tell us anything that you can about it I
can't tell you much other than we are
making the movie we start in September
it is very much a sequel to the first
film but also an adaptation of Marx
books kick-ass 2 and and we we push
things further you know in every sense
what I loved about the first film and
what Matthew did was it was so emotional
and felt very honest and I think we we
push that even further in the second
film but then we also do what Mark does
in the comics where he sort of pushes
the boundaries of the superhero genre
and we do that as well in the second
film so I think I think people who love
the first film are gonna be quite
pleased with the second
who are we talking about in terms of
costs and who's returning characters for
kick-ass - well no one is confirmed yet
but I will say that the script is very
much an ensemble piece that focuses on
Dave the kick-ass character and and
Chris red mist who becomes a super
villain in this movie and changes his
name from red mist to the [ __ ]
am I allowed to say that at this
interview and and Mindy who's Hit Girl
and just as she did in the kick-ass 2
book she gives up being Hit Girl the
difference is in the movie we're gonna
spend a lot of time with her and see
what it means when you when you take a
real superhero who and that's what Hit
Girl is and she tries to be a regular
kid sort of the opposite of what Dave
did in the first film you talk about
obviously adapting the comic books here
Howard kind of involved in that side of
the process are you and how do you
envisage it how do you visit it going
well I wrote script so you know I worked
closely with Matthew and with Mark and
would constantly be emailing them and
asking questions but for me it was
really about finding an intersection
between the sequel to the first film and
an adaptation of the comics because you
know if you know the comics well the the
first film takes some liberties right so
if the you know here's the first comic
and here's the first film and then the
second series of the of the books were a
sequel to the the first series I just
sort of find this intersection right
where we were being where we're creating
an honest sequel to the first film but
we're also adapting the books so it's
challenging but I loved it and I loved
the characters and so I had a really
good time doing and actually it came
came to me quite quickly I think I wrote
it in about six weeks did a couple weeks
of work with Matthew and that's the
drafter shooting how is it stepping into
the shoes of Matthew Vaughn and Jane
Goldman as the writer and director of
kick-ass - it's quite intimidating
because they are so incredibly talented
but they created this fantastic
foundation which I get to build off of
so you know in a weird way I get to
benefit from their their their talent
and all their hard work and take credit
for much of it and and as I mentioned
Matthew is intimately involved with
kick-ass - as a producer I
speak to him for hours every day he's a
producers he's a filmmakers dream when
it comes to a producer because he has
empowered me to make my movie at the
same time you know kick ass is his baby
so he's very involved and we just have a
fantastic collaboration and and so in a
weird way too he even though he didn't
write the screenplay and he's not
directing it
he has his fingerprints all over it now
how much the game change did you think
this film's going to be for you why I
hope I become fabulously rich and famous
afterwards no I don't know
I mean look I've been doing this long
enough I've been in the film business
for ten years that that all I really
want out of a project is the opportunity
to tell a story that I love and I care
about that reaches the largest audience
possible and so if we achieve that with
kick-ass - I will be ecstatic and how
you finding it now that you're in Lindy
sleeping here for five days and there's
many more to come yet
yeah I'm basically moving here for a
year because we're gonna shoot a movie
here and post it here it's a British
film but an American story and I think
that's one of the reasons why the first
film works so well because it's
referencing all this sort of iconography
that we associate with sort of American
superheroes but it had a very British
sensibility and so I'm enjoying trying
to recreate that for the sequel and so I
think being here is a big part of that
and and it's a little scary moving to a
new city for so long but again we have
the same family on the first film a lot
of the crew is returning and because
they're so loyal to Matthew and
obviously he attracts the best and the
brightest and the business and they've
welcomed me with open arms so I'm so far
so good
what would you ideally want to be doing
next kick-ass 3 of course now I mean
truthfully to be completely candid about
a year ago I was talking to my
girlfriend and I had a couple projects
that were
supposed to get may and then didn't get
off the ground and I was quite
frustrated which is all part of you know
working in Hollywood and my girlfriend
said to me if you know a year from now
you can be making any kind of movie what
kind of movie would that be
and I I described a movie that is pretty
much kick-ass - so in many ways that's a
hard question to answer because it's
already come true for me you know I'm
living my dream now making this movie
well that's great to hear
and we cannot wait to see kick ass - it
goes without saying and lots of look for
the filming of it thank you very much I
really appreciate
you